check this out so this is from Molson
cores which owns Miller Lite and Coors
this is an internal ad so this was not
publicly this this was not put out as a
as an advertisement to the public this
was internal messaging to their own
employees that got leaked out and look
how wokeness man give the devil is due
it destroys everything
at motion cores we know that diversity
equity and inclusion matter
diversity is a good thing because
everyone is unique in their experiences
points of views and the brands they
identified with
our point of view is that our employees
need to be as diverse as our consumers
who are Acid versus our products
it's part of our 2021 to 2023 Workforce
strategy we have challenged ourselves to
increase our representation of
Professionals of color both in the US
and Canada we're also committed to
increasing the representation of women
in our workplace to be reflective of
Market where we work and live
and we expect to achieve one billion
dollars of spin with diverse suppliers
in the Americas
we have provided education and dedicated
training to all employees to increase
their awareness and understanding of how
diversity equity and inclusion are
embedded into our culture and since 2020
we have maintained an annual 1.5 million
dollar investment in community
organizations focus on social justice
equity and empowerment
as we look forward Muslim course will
continue to make diversity equity and
inclusion part of everything that we do
if you just bashed your head against
your desk for the last 38 seconds you're
very similar to me just absolutely
insane that line something to the effect
of our employees needs to be as diverse
as our customers what would think how
insane that what do you mean what do you
mean if a third of your customers are
black lesbians then a third of your
employees should be black lesbians also
to black lesbians drink Coors Light I
feel like they would that seems that
seems right to me
um yeah Daphne I got a big nod from
Daphne on that one black lesbians love
Coors Light it's all so idiotic if you
were making a product let's say you were
making a glass to put water in or a
coaster to put that glass on or a pen or
some chapstick
or a box of tissues how many things do I
have on this desk or a lens cap well I
don't know why this is on my desk right
now someone fixed that later if you were
doing any of those things what would you
do you'd be like all right I've got this
idea for a product and I'm going to
start a company here so you have to fill
out some paperwork now first would you
go to a lawyer and be like uh can I get
a can I get a black uh partly
handicapped lawyer possibly with a
little Native American uh in there could
you is that and then you build out the
product I don't want these type it's so
stupid these people are trying to make
beer guys generally drink beer I don't
really like beer I find if I have even
half a beer I get bloated I like tequila
okay and I don't care I assume that most
of the people making my tequila are
Mexican but frankly it doesn't matter if
you know how to make tequila and you're
Asian
you could be an Asian little person
making tequila that would be fine with
me too
so ironic
[Music]
thank you